is it possible to sound gay we know many
of the factors that shape our identities
from race to geography to disability can
impact the way we use language so what
about gender and sexuality
lavender language refers to the speech
practices of lgbtq plus people and the
linguists who study it have chronicled a
rich global history that has thrived in
secrecy for decades I'm Dr Erica
brazovsky and this is other words
[Music]
other words
in the 1990s Anthropologist William leap
wanted to study the way people of
different lgbtq plus identities speak
and chose lavender a slang synonym for
gay or Queer as an umbrella term leap
wasn't the first to study lavender
language the term he used came from a
dictionary of gay slang written in the
1940s but his work defined a field of
study that covers everything from how
queer people use pronouns to the word
play of gossip and insults to queer
vernaculars or Argos the complex and
sometimes secret vocabularies of lgbtq
plus communities one of the most famous
and well-documented gay Argos is polari
which was used by gay men in England
until the late 1960s it borrowed from
all kinds of speaking groups on the
fringes of society like thieves Sailors
theater performers and Romani people
polari speakers would Rhyme or reverse
words or borrow from other languages to
create new slang some polari words that
we still use are Naf meaning tacky or
unfashionable or the verb for sprucing
up your hair or outfit that's fun to say
but impossible to spell in the late 60s
pillari started to show up in popular
music and television shows sort of like
how contemporary queer and trans
Ballroom slang has gotten popularized
through shows like drag race
at the same time Britain repealed part
of its anti-homosexuality laws making
the secret code less necessary for
safety polari started to fall out of
regular use in the gay community
suffering a significant blow when many
of the remaining polari speakers died in
the AIDS crisis of the 1980s still
lavender linguists continued to study
and document pilari to preserve this
important part of lgbtq plus history but
for much of its history polari was
somewhat of a secret code when
homosexuality was criminalized in the UK
slipping polari phrases into everyday
speech could help you identify who else
around you was also gay without being
obvious to straight people polari also
had slang names for police like Lily law
or Jennifer justice so that gay men
could warn each other that police were
around without them noticing some
features of polari also live on in other
lavender languages around the globe
luxuro an Argo based on Spanish spoken
by trans people and sex workers in Peru
has a similar coded nature reversing
words adding extra syllables like dosoro
and kuti Ola becomes osurolasara and
Mama becomes makuti this feature called
cryptolization allows luxuro speakers to
discuss taboo topics around listeners
they may not know or trust Gail an Argo
that arose in apartheid South Africa
among gay men of color also borrows from
polari and mixes it with English and
Afrikaans
Gail's main feature is using
alliteration to substitute women's names
for other common words
just like palar referred to police as
Jennifer Justice Gale speakers might
talk about avoiding Betty Bengals or
getting Dora at a patsy instead of
drinking at a party Gail like polari
employs a common feature of lavender
languages sheeng or using feminine
language for non-feminine subjects just
like how gay men in the U.S might refer
to friends as girl sister or queen
lavender languages have a long tradition
of playfulness with gender to challenge
our ideas about language and power using
feminine language reverses the cultural
hierarchies that put masculine people at
the top of the social order and feminine
queer and trans people at the bottom
according to Lavender linguist Paul
Baker Xiang is inverting mainstream
society's values so that everybody's
potentially gay and everybody's
potentially feminine that's also how
speakers of sward speak also called
simply gay lingo in the Philippines
describe their use of language the mix
of tagalogs Spanish English and some
Japanese that began in the 1970s is
known as a mode of social resistance for
the way that it allows speakers to play
with gendered language rules of the
languages they speak like the other
Argos we discussed sword speak is used
to immediately identify other speakers
as queer and can also be pretty useful
for gossiping or talking behind people's
backs in a way that not everybody can
understand but speakers say it's no
longer a secret as it used to be in fact
in circles that contain a lot of lgbtq
plus people like the Fashion Beauty and
entertainment Industries swartzbeek has
spread to women and even some straight
men swardspeak is not just a
multilingual mashup it's also filled
with celebrity references you might call
an inexpensive outfit Mariah Carey
because Mariah sounds like Mora the
Tagalog word for cheap and julianus
Morissette means to Reign from the
Tagalog word for rain Ulan and the
iconic line from the song Ironic using
smartspeak requires a lot of complex
cultural knowledge there are borrowed
words from half a dozen languages in
deep pop culture cuts that can take
speakers years of engaging with the gay
community to be able to fully understand
this helps solidify the in-group
identities of speakers through the act
of creating language together some
sports big users say that gay lingo is
like verbal Jazz where speakers are
constantly riffing and innovating off of
each other to keep this lavender
language evolving these are by no means
the only lavender languages that exist
as the field grows researchers from all
over the world gather each year to talk
about new developments in lgbtq plus
language use and there's so much more to
learn many of the examples we discussed
today are lavender languages used by
cisgender gay men because they're some
of the most researched queer Argos still
trans and gender non-conforming people
are also innovating language practices
like repopularizing the use of the
singular they or introducing themselves
with pronouns when meeting new people
while there's so much more to study
lavender Linguistics reminds us that
celebrating our own identities is a
doorway into a Freer and more expansive
expression of ourselves and that there
is no more direct means of expression
than language
okay
[Music]
[Laughter]
ah